allez on en vient présent à ce cche qui
nous est signalé ce matin dans la région
de de belgoronne dont vous allez
apercevoir les toutes premières images
un avion de transport militaire russe
avec à son bord 65 prisonniers de guerre
ukrainien c'est écrasé ce matin près de
la la frontière ukrainienne
l'appareil se déplaca en vue visiblement
d'un d'un échange vous apercevez ici des
images amateures qui circulent sur les
les réseaux sociaux et montrant donc
l'explosion de l'appareil juste avant
visiblement cette grosse exp exposion
l'engin a plongé à pic on va retrouver
tout de suite Guliver Kra qui not
correspondant à Kiev pour tenter d'y
voir plus clair sur ces événement
Guliver bonjour c'eston ce qui s'est
passé dans cette région au moment de ce
crash alors ce sont uniquement les
Russes pour le moment qui disent qu'il y
avait ces 63 prisonniers de guerre
Ukrainiens à bord de cet avion les
Ukrainiens n'ont pas confirmé cette
information il n'y a aucune réaction
officielle en Ukraine pour le moment
mais une source militaire citée dans les
médias Ukrainiens dit que il n'y avait
pas de prisonniers de guerre à bord mais
bien des componentss pour les systèmes
de roquettes S300 qui sont utilisés très
souvent pour frapper la région de harkiv
et cette source disait que effectivement
ce sont les Ukrainiens qui ont abattu
cet avion mais je répète cela n'a pas
été confirmé officiellement pour le
moment tout ce qu'on sait c'est que
l'avion est tombé et euh il y a euh les
informations venant uniquement pour le
moment du côté russe comme quoi il y
aurait eu ces prisonniers de guerre à
bord dans les médias russes il y a aussi
des informations comme quoi il y aurait
eu un deuxième avion qui a fait
demi-tour pour éviter d'être abattu lui
aussi lui aussi transportant des
prisonniers de bord mais encore une fois
on ne peut pas le le confirmer là les
les Russes on voit des accusations dans
leurs médias extrêmement sévère contre
les Ukrainiens les accusons d'avoir fait
exprès de tuer leurs propres prisonniers
de guerre l' à l'instant c'est le
président de la Douma en personne le
Parlement russe qui accuse Kiev d'avoir
abattu l'avion en question il parle d'un
avion de prisonnier ukrainien donc il
reste sur sur cette thèse là vous y
faisiez référence Guliver c'est vrai que
ces derniers temps la Russie a tendance
à pointter du doigt
l'Ukraine mais je vous rappelle que la
Russie a aussi accusé l'Ukraine d'être
gouverné par des nazis et toutes sortes
d'autres accusations qui ne sont
évidemment pas du tout vrai je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse considérer les sources
russes comme fiables tout cela étant dit
il est évidemment possible que les
Ukrainiens aient fait une terrible
erreur en pensant que cet avion
transportterit des pièces pour les
systèmes de roquettes
S300 l'Ukraine tente effectivement
d'éliminer ses systèmes de requettes sur
le territoire russe en exécutant euh des
des frappes et et en tentant d'abattre
des des avions des avions russes je
pense qu'on doit attendre un peu plus de
temps pour voir quelle sera la réaction
officielle ukrainienne l'armée de l'air
doit faire une déclaration je pense dans
dans les heures qui viennent